si creó lo que están diciendo porque
justamente el día de ayer la reserva
Federal Tuvo una reunión de emergencia y
lo que lograron fue crear una nueva
facilidad para darle liquidez a todos
los bancos que la necesiten y además
decidieron junto con el tesoro
rescatar a los depositantes todos los
depósitos por encima de 250 mil dólares
van a ser garantizados por el gobierno
cosa que antes no existía esto es
totalmente nuevo entonces no van a ver
repercusiones blindaron el sistema con
esta nueva Norma y por lo tanto yo no
esperaría un efecto dominó tanto en
Estados Unidos como global
Sí pero sí hay suficiente dinero para
responderles a todas esas personas que
seguramente van a querer retirar todos
sus bancos intervenido no
Sí exactamente el cine chur Bank Y sí sí
van a haber suficientes
suficiente dinero para hacerle frente
porque el tesoro y la reserva Federal
juntos están abordando este tema
Entonces yo no vería un tema sistémico
Honestamente por la decisión que se tomó
anoche en una reunión de emergencia
Daniel Esta es una es un banco de
startups tecnológicas básicamente Cómo
puede ese colapso afectar
específicamente esta industria
que está basada a muchos de ellos En
California pero también en América
Latina hay un efecto algún efecto en
empresas que estén en la región y que de
pronto tuvieran sus ahorros allá en ese
banco
pues previo a este anuncio de que salió
anoche que les mencioné sí había un
riesgo bastante significativo Porque si
una empresa tenía por encima de 250 mil
dólares depositados en alguno de estos
bancos perdía ese dinero todo por encima
de 250.000 lo perdía entonces esos
capital de trabajo para empresas nuevas
son empresas que no tienen
necesariamente ingresos porque son
tecnológicas entonces dependen mucho del
flujo que ya tienen en sus arcas en
estos depósitos Si eso no hubiera sido
blindado entonces hubiéramos visto un
efecto dominó sobre silicon Valley un
montón de estos hubieran quedado
quebradas y por lo tanto despidos de
personas no pagos a proveedores
hubiera sido un tema que hubiera tenido
repercusiones bastante bastante fuertes
en Estados Unidos y si en Estados Unidos
sucede algo en América Latina nos llega
inmediato verdad entonces también
hubiese habido
los efectos en Latinoamérica porque
habían empresas
de latinoamérica y de Europa que También
tenían sus cuentas en estos dos bancos
Entonces por suerte llegó este anuncio
anoche del gobierno y brindó todo este
riesgo sistémico y eso lo que das como
una especie de parte de tranquilidad
para las personas y para las empresas
que tenían su dinero allí pero todo esto
comienza Daniel con la subida de tasas
de la reserva Federal que mucha gente
piensa que eso no va a tener efectos
inmediatos pero mire este es uno de los
efectos de que el banco de Central de
Estados Unidos haya comenzado a subir
las tasas de interés por qué Porque no
nos cuenta un poquito Cómo fue Cómo se
llega a este colapso
buena pregunta entonces todo sucede con
todo inicia el Génesis son los programas
de estímulo monetario que las bancos
centrales especialmente la reserva
Federal empezaron a hacer desde la
pandemia fuertemente Entonces qué
significa eso las tasas estuvieron en
cero por varios años y eso es lo que
fomenta es crecimiento en las Industrias
que necesitan financiamiento barato
Entonces por ejemplo tecnología
tecnología necesita tasas Bajas para
poder endeudarse barato y para que
entonces proyectos que tendrán
rentabilidad a largo plazo puedan tener
financiamiento hoy Entonces eso generó
que bancos como svb que estaban
dedicadas a Estados tecnológicas de
repente vieron un ingreso enorme de
depósitos en cuentas de Starbucks que
son inversores invirtiendo en estos
storeos y esos dineros caen en los
depósitos de los bancos por supuesto
verdad Entonces este banco empezó a
tener una liquidez muy grande y tiene
dos opciones que puede hacer con esa
liquidez prestarla en forma de préstamos
y créditos o invertirlas en títulos del
gobierno decidieron invertir en títulos
del gobierno y los compraron en precios
bastante
altos verdad y lo que sucedió es que
cuando la empezó a subir tasas golpeó
los precios de esos bonos que ya tenían
en sus carteras les generó pérdidas Y
entonces La Tormenta perfecta se dio que
clientes de su que tenían cuentas en
este banco trataron de ir a buscar
mayores rendimientos porque no estaban
remunerando bien las cuentas corrientes
este banco y todos los demás bancos
Estados Unidos entonces sacaron dineros
del banco y el banco Entonces se vio
forzado a vender los bonos a pérdida Y
eso generó un evento de destrucción en
su balance